turning to the war in Ukraine the
country's armed forces are getting more
weapons from the West as they prepare
for a counter-offensive that's expected
this spring Holly Williams is in Ukraine
getting a rare look at the armed forces
that are getting ready to take on the
Russian troops Holly good morning to you
good morning well Ukraine says it's
taken delivery of a long-awaited patriot
air defense system that's U.S technology
that can shoot down aircraft and
missiles but we've been meeting with
some Ukrainian soldiers that are still
hoping for New American weapons
through dense forest in eastern Ukraine
down muddy tracks we were taken to see
something hidden amongst the trees an
entire Battalion of Ukraine's third tank
Brigade known as the iron Brigade their
machines are well camouflaged so they
can't be spotted by Russian drones this
one's a 1980s era tank
pretty old technology
they're not state of the art these are
all soviet-made tanks more than three
decades old
but they allow the ukrainians to
penetrate deep into territory occupied
by Russia you can hit something 12
kilometers that's eight miles away
Vladimir is a tank commander who told us
he used to serve in the Soviet Army
alongside Russian comrades back when
Ukraine was part of the USSR now the
Russians are his enemy
Ukraine's new friends the US and its
European allies are sending more capable
modern tanks including 31 Abrams from
America expected later this year
Ukraine's government calls tanks the
punching fist of democracy
for Vladimir the Abrams can't come soon
enough
my parents lived here my children live
here my grandchildren live here Vladimir
told us this is our land
the soldiers Manning those tanks asked
us to pass on their thanks to the
American people for their support and
that's something that we've heard over
and over again here in Ukraine Tony
and now the American people are hearing
it as well Holly Williams for us in
Ukraine Holly thank you very much